Lykos hits just keep on coming
after its first detection of merging
black holes swiftly followed by finding
three more and then a Nobel Prize the
pair of gravitational wave detectors has
made yet another huge discovery
on August 17 2017 the observatory
detected gravitational waves from two
neutron stars spiralling together and
merging just two seconds later a
so-called gamma-ray burst was detected
by NASA's orbiting Fermi gamma-ray Space
Telescope and its Swift Space Telescope
12 hours after the wave was detected a
team from Las Campanas Observatory in
Chile reported a new glowing optical
source in galaxy NGC 4 993 that was
consistent with these findings and with
the advanced tip from LIGO both radio
and x-ray emissions were found a few
days later coming from the same
neighborhood not only is this the first
time LIGO has detected gravitational
waves from a neutron star collision it's
also the first time that electromagnetic
observations from conventional
telescopes accompany the gravitational
waves at wavelengths ranging from ultra
short gamma rays to very long radio
waves the event was seen by
observatories around the world because
we now have visual information to go
along with the gravitational waves new
discoveries are being made about the
nature of neutron stars the light coming
from the collision showed spectral
traces of lanthanides a group of heavier
elements towards the bottom of the
periodic table this strongly suggests
that merging neutron stars have been
responsible for the creation of heavy
elements such as gold and platinum a
long-held theory not only that but the
shape of the gamma ray burst was
unusually weak gamma-ray bursts are
usually so strong that researchers
assume that the gamma rays emerge from
two back-to-back jets that shoot out of
an explosion like narrow spotlights the
weaker gamma-ray burst suggests it was
produced when broader Jets slammed into
a cocoon of matter surrounding the
merged neutron stars while this finding
is home to a lot of firsts it won't
the last researchers are positive that
with the large amount of gamma-ray
events out there and the increase in
both gravitational and electromagnetic
detector sensitivity we'll be seeing a
lot more of these combination events in
the future
[Music]
you